ethiopia's prime minister abi ahmed says
the army has been ordered to move on the
capital of the northern tigrai region
in what he's calling the final phase of
the offensive
some half a million residents of the
capital mckelly have been warned to stay
indoors
the move comes just hours after an
ultimatum expired for regional leaders
to surrender to the central government
the un is warning it's running low on
essential supplies for the nearly one
million people who've been displaced by
the conflict
our correspondent marielle muller
reports
we are only 80 kilometers away from the
ethiopian border into the region of
tigray where heavy fighting still
continues
this u.n camp called umra cuba camp once
housed refugees who fled ethiopia's
famine in the 1980s
now the camp is expected to house
several thousand refugees
as the u.n refugee agency told us many
more than the original capacity of six
thousand people here are desperate they
tell us water food and shelter are
scarce
some of them have to sleep on the ground
are struggling to get enough food or
medical aid
the new refugees crossing the border to
sudan worry aid groups
a representative told us we are unable
to respond to a growing influx
umbra cuba camp once housed refugees who
fled ethiopia's famine in the 1980s
now some 9 000 people have saved
themselves once again
but this time it's because of war in
this hospital
people wait for hours before receiving
treatment
like agare she her baby and her father
escaped the war in the tigrayan town of
humera
i was afraid because the bombs kept
falling
for three days we just left without
money
without clothes it took ten days to come
here
and now we're here in sudan we've been
in this camp for three days
we don't have any shelter
her father has terminal cancer since
they got out he hasn't received his
medication
the un refugee agency is bracing for
more refugees crossing the border from
ethiopia
people need everything from water food
and shelter so at the moment we are
catering for over 9000 people at a
hot meal to our partner
and that's not enough and it's children
who are suffering the most
it's estimated that half of the refugees
are children
many of them need medical treatment like
five-month-old kal-ab
he's been coughing and has had diarrhea
since days
i can't breastfeed him and here they
don't have milk powder
and the food the baby needs
outside the hospital we meet allen whose
house was bombed in humera
the site of reportedly some of the
heaviest fighting between ethiopian
forces
and the tigrayan army he got shot in the
leg
i'm alone my mom and my dad were killed
by the bombing these clothes are my only
ones
i wear them for days nobody helps me
i don't have enough water or food here
nobody takes care of me
if more refugees arrive alem fears that
the situation
could get even worse
you